the court in france has found former
president nicolas sarkozy guilty of
corruption and
influence peddling the judge has handed
sarkozy a three-year prison sentence
two of which are suspended the 66 year
old
is the second leader in france's modern
history to be convicted
of corruption natasha butler is live for
us at the court in paris natasha
run us through uh what exactly he's been
found guilty of
and does this mean that we're going to
see a former president now heading to
prison
yes uh nicholas sarkozy becoming
the first former french president to be
handed
a jail sentence he was found guilty by
the court here
in paris of corruption and influence
peddling and he's been handed
a three-year jail sentence so we
understand two years
suspended the third year he may be able
to carry out
under house arrest now lawyers for
nicolas sarkozy say
that he does intend to appeal now this
case uh
focused on an incident in 2014 in which
sarkozy
was charged with trying to influence the
magistrate trying to offer this
magistrate
a top job in return for information
into another investigation which was
being carried out at the time by police
on nicolas sarkozy over uh campaign
funds
now nicholas sarkozy during the trial
always protested his innocence he said
that
uh that he had been the victim of a
political smear campaign but it seems
that the judge here in paris disagreed
handing out this uh jail sentence a
devastating blow indeed
uh to nicolas sarkozy so what then might
this mean natasha
for sarkozy's political ambitions
[Music]
well sarkozy served as president of
france a conservative president from
2007 to
but since he left office since he left
uh the elysee he has really been you
might say
trying to stage a political comeback in
2017
he even ran once again uh for the
presidency
and uh over the years he certainly tried
to position himself as a hope for the
conservative party perhaps for another
presidential election campaign but you'd
have to say that this guilty verdict
cerny
will deal a blow to those ambitions it
would be hard to imagine
that a former president with now a jail
sentence to contend with could possibly
uh take the center stage once again
uh politically so very disappointing for
sarkozy
uh his reputation in tatters you might
say but as i said the former french
leader
making it very clear that he will appeal
okay thank you for that
natasha butler live for us at the court
in paris